Let's discuss more about
network IDS deployment.
Here's an example enterprise
network configuration.
The internal network
has multiple subnets.
And the enterprise has public-facing
services, such as a public web server.
Recall our lecture on firewalls.
We typically want to place
an external firewall
to protect the entire
enterprise network.
In addition,
we want to protect the internal network
from the public-facing servers.
These servers are put in what we
call a DMZ and we use internal
firewalls to monitor traffic between
the internal subnet and a DMZ.
The internal firewalls also monitor
traffic between its subnets.
So that's the deployment of firewalls,
but what about IDS?
A common location for an IDS sensor
is just inside the external firewall.
This position has
a number of advantages.
Obviously, you can see attacks
from the outside world.
By comparing the logs of the firewall
and the IDS, we can also
find out whether the firewall had missed
an attack that it should have prevented.
The IDS at this location can also
detect attacks that are targeted at
the public facing servers.
In addition, because it can analyze
all outgoing traffic of the entire
enterprise network, it can also detect
attacks from a compromised server,
either from DMZ or the internal network.
A network IDS can also be placed between
the external network and the Internet.
The main advantage of this location
is that the network IDS can see
all attempted attacks to
the enterprise network,
including those attacks that have
been filtered by the firewalls.
For example, if the firewall is
overloaded, you would not only drop
the incoming packet, it may not even
have resource to log this packet.
But an IDS at this location
can see the packet and log it.
Therefore, the IDS can see
all attempted attacks.
In addition to deploying
network IDS at the perimeter,
we can also deploy a network IDS to
protect a subnet or set of servers.
A network IDS at this location can
perform more detailed analysis of
traffic data.
Because compared with a network
IDS at the perimeter,
it has smaller amount of traffic volume,
due to the fact that it only monitors
traffic to a subnet and the servers.
In addition, it can also detect
intrusions from inside the network.
In addition to protecting the servers,
a network IDS can also be placed
to protect the workstations or networks
of important personnels or departments.
A network IDS at this location can
focus on targeted attacks, for
example, attacks that are targeted
at financial transaction systems.
Compared with an IDS at
the network perimeter,
which must examine traffic to
the whole network, an IDS at
this location can instead focus on
traffic to these high-value systems.